our main story this morning Downing
Street's accused Nigel Farage of being
desperate for attention after the UK
bleeder suggested Britain's race laws
are outdated and ought to be scrapped
well let's get more on this now Nigel
Farage made the comments and an
interview for a documentary let's have a
look and listen of the clip that started
the rau situation that we now have where
an employer is not allowed to choose
between a british-born person and
somebody from Poland is is a ludicrous
state of affairs I think you should be
able to choose on the basis of
nationality yes I do well the Labour MP
Sadiq Khan is among those critical of Mr
Farage I think Nigel Farage demonstrates
better taking ignorance he doesn't
understand the history of our country or
the importance of Vantage termination
laws that led to the improvements we've
seen over the last 20 30 years the idea
that we've reached state of utopia and
things are perfect is ridiculous we
weren't employers to choose young
Britons to take on job because they're
the best people for the job not because
they're white or because they're
Britain's necessaries well in the last
couple of minutes ed Miliband has waded
in through our let's hear what he said I
believe that the Britain should be proud
of the fact that we're a tolerant
country were a country with people of
different faiths different backgrounds
I'm proud of that and I believe that the
laws that we have on equality are an
incredibly important part of meeting the
very British value that we treat
everybody the same whatever their
background whatever their religion I
think Nigel Farage is comments today are
wrong they're divisive and they're
dangerous just fine so is the UK per
litre right our racial discrimination
work laws outdated joining us now to
discuss that as her Eenie I anger who's
a barrister specializing in
discrimination and employment law and
Steven Moxon joins us also he's a former
home office whistleblower and now author
of the great immigration scandal thanks
both of you very much for joining us
before we get started remind you can
join the debate at home you can email
tweet us at the all the usual address is
at
going to use at Jane second sky
including the hashtag sky debate text
article 50 on email news at sky com let
us know what you think hurry knee I
ain't got let's talk to you first these
laws that that Nigel Farage is talking
about are 50 years old are they right
for some kind of updating at least well
they're 50 years old because after the
Second World War countries got together
and Britain was one of those leading
countries at the time and said in order
to avoid another war let's try and get a
universal declaration of human rights so
the laws that we've got in this country
on race discrimination had derived from
fundamental values and human rights
treating people equally and we have the
race relations act 1976 and different
statutes on for example disability
discrimination in sex discrimination
they all got updated and consolidated
into the equality act 2010 so if the law
that has been criticized is actually a
new and up-to-date law okay Steven Moxon
it's new it's up to date and it's about
upholding British society British values
nothing what were to do is that the
breathtaking ignorance is why the way
past year the e co op didn't first that
legislation be based on identity
politics which is backlash by the West
against the map of ordinary people the
long complicated terms his ginger vinyl
and a dbacks circa nineteen thirty I've
written a paper on this was not going to
it now but it's not about being
considerate to my neurologist it's about
contempt and texture for majority in any
case Nigel Farage columns are nothing to
do with the race and race ethnicity and
he pointed out himself to do with a
problem of employers outsourcing and the
need for employers forgiveness we can
choose indigenous people was there black
or white and a corresponds down amazing
the moment our recently immigrated
ethnic minorities if the BBC newsnight
want to find people disgruntled with
mass immigration to go to inner-city
Birmingham thought generation Carini I
anger what have these laws achieved over
the last 50 years
at the most basic level they've provided
people in the country with a peaceful
and civilized way of sorting out their
quarrels so most employers are
interested in having a productive
workplace most employers in my
experience want to hire somebody who's
got the right skills the right
experience and a hard working attitude
similarly most workers want to get on
with the job do well at it and get paid
for it sometimes unfortunately people
can't agree and people think they've
been treated unfairly these laws allow
the employer and the employee to go to a
forum which is the court called an
employment tribunal which they both
trust and respect and have that their
quarrel sorted out in a peaceful and
civilized way I can't imagine how the
country would get along and how business
would get along if we didn't have a
court mechanism for dealing with these
kind of disputes Stephen box and what
wilds racism still exists in our society
whilst inequality still exists in our
society don't we need to keep these laws
no because they're overzealous in the
way that they frame and the way they
actually apply and also it's not looking
if we look in racism it's not looking
for a sin in the right places as the
research shows that the basis of race
them is what term in group love Robin a
group hate it's loosely strongest but
people are feel threatened to or the not
the indigenous majority but recently
arrived at mike-mike in 10 plays and so
gracefully was actually more apparent
blackonwhite far as I found when I lived
in inner-city Lester into ethnic the
problem they was the greatest and by a
pro caribbean's to variation group hurry
knee I anger can we get you to respond
to that I'm not really sure what he's
saying is he saying could you ask me a
question well I mean do you think
looking at these laws and looking at how
they operate we're talking about racism
in society and how our society is I'm
wondering if you think does having these
kind of laws stop people being racist it
perhaps stops racist practices but you
think fundamentally they change society
over time do they make society better do
they change people's minds order the
just perhaps change the way they
act I think these laws do help it they
are a process that takes time they help
in two ways first of all if you're a
minority or protect one of the protected
categories which includes women and
disabled people to just to give two
examples it makes you feel that you've
got a place in society as a worker and
that you're respected if you work hard
and you've got the skills and experience
you're going to be treated as an equal
and the second thing is on obviously you
know if you've been discriminated
against it gives you a financial remedy
which makes a big difference to
individuals and if you're an employer
and you think I've chosen someone to do
this job or have promoted someone
because of business reasons that I can
justify you can go to the tribunal to
and you can say look I've not been
racist I'm running my business in a
businesslike way for good reasons the
other way is that it opens up a whole
debate hink about what is race
discrimination for example we've had
cases about when people shouldn't
shouldn't wear turbans you know whether
you should or shouldn't be able to cover
your mouth if you're teaching in a
primary school and you wish to wear a
veil it allows society and requires
businesses to have training and open
their minds and have some quite awkward
conversations about what if a disabled
person wants to work here have we got
wheelchair access can we afford to
create wheelchair access if we don't is
there anything else we can do and we
have all kinds of training and policies
that we just wouldn't have if employees
were left to their own devices I think
okay afraid thou must leave it hi how
many I anger and Steve mocks and thank
you both very much